this is absolutely bizarre
for a number of reasons donald trump's
indicted
former national security adviser michael
flynn
who has since been pardoned and is a
total out and out conspiracy theorist
appeared on some right wing show a few
days ago and claimed that
yes the election was stolen and yes
covid was a conspiracy
and all of this stuff but as crazy as
all of that is
he drops in he's not worried because
he's been on hydroxychloroquine for 30
years
what why has he been on
hydroxychloroquine for 30 years
and why would you need to be on
hydroxychloroquine if covet is a hoax
anyway
none of it's make none of it makes sense
why has he been taking the virus uh why
why has he been taking the medication
what did he know in 1991 at age 32
that would start him on a 30-year course
of hydroxychloroquine just some of the
questions
that come up let's take a listen to
michael flynn and because when you look
around the world and you go well
all these other places why aren't all
these other places having the kinds of
problems that
that work we keep getting beat over the
head and shoulders on in this country
about when it comes to covet
why because everything everything and
this is
this is my my truth but what i believe
everything is a distraction to what
happened on the 3rd of november
so everything that we hear about kovid
and that covid started before the third
of november
but it was all meant to control it's all
meant to gain
control of a society to be able to to
force decisions on the society instead
of actually allowing we the
people to make decisions imagine for a
moment and this is the this is the
tragedy
that guy was the national security
adviser of the united states for a
period of time
okay i've heard from other people
the idea kovid was created
slash released to make trump lose the
election
this is one of the conspiracies that
doesn't even make sense in terms of the
motive
sometimes you have a bad conspiracy
theory and all they have is motive they
have no facts
but at least the motive sort of might
work to convince you that it's a
possible conspiracy
kovit was created to make trump lose the
american election
doesn't even pass the sniff test because
there's no guarantee
that kovid would make a world leader up
for re-election lose if they handled the
virus correctly never mind that we've
had six hundred thousand official deaths
the world has had three and a half
million official deaths most of the
deaths are not in the u.s
so flynn is wrong that we are mostly
affected and everybody else is fine most
of the deaths have been in other
countries
second if you handle covet well you get
yourself re-elected
look at new zealand where jacinda ardern
handled the virus
beautifully easily got re-elected and
new zealand was able to reopen much
earlier than the united states so
to assume trump loses because of kovid
is sort of silly unless you assume trump
would mishandle it which isn't as crazy
but it still goes against the idea of
what michael flynn is saying
but then he casually mentions i've been
on hydroxychloroquine for 30 years
and now with the with the vaccine as an
example right whatever happened to the
woman's movement
out there for the my body my choice but
yet
they want to stick a a needle in in my
arm
to tell me that well if you don't have
that needle you can't get an id card you
can't get you can't travel
wait a second i'm as healthy as an
expert i've been i've been taking
hydrochloroquine for 30 years
okay so by by the way more lies there no
one has said you can't get a state id if
you don't get a vaccine
and in terms of travel there are
countries that
are putting in place a vaccine
requirement for covet vaccine
for decades and decades different
countries have had different vaccine
requirements
that's nothing new okay but
hydroxychloroquine for 30 years
michael flynn is 62 years old right now
meaning 30 years ago he would have been
32 and it would have been 1991.
why did he start taking
hydroxychloroquine in 1991 at 32 years
of age
has he had arthritis in sage 32 one of
the reasons sometimes people take
hydroxychloroquine
has he been persistently exposed to
malaria for the last 30 years where he
needs to
constantly be on hydroxychloroquine has
he had lupus
since age 32 another reason why
sometimes you would take
hydroxychloroquine
if you take it for just five years
you need to get regular eye exams
because it can cause
retinopathy and michael flynn claims
that he's been on hydroxychloroquine for
30
years or is michael flynn implying that
as a prophylactic of some kind he's been
taking hydroxychloroquine for 30 years
which just makes no sense whatsoever
um and i i got one funny email which was
you know maybe 30 years of
hydroxychloroquine
have caused some kind of toxicity and
that explains all of michael flynn's
bizarre behavior
the paranoid delusions the conspiracy
theories all of it i don't know
and to come back again to the entire
covet hoax thing
if it's a hoax why do you need to take
anything
why take hydroxychloroquine for
something that's not real
if that's indeed what you believe and of
course by hoax they always mean
different things sometimes by hoax they
mean it's not really a virus and
nobody's dying from it
by hoax sometimes they mean no it's a
real virus and people are dying
but it was deliberately released to have
a political impact either on the united
states or the world or whatever the case
may be
it's never clear their conspiracy
theories conflict
but what is abundantly clear here is
that michael flynn is
completely off the rails and it is
terrifying
terrifying that that guy at one point
was the primary and most important
advisor on the topic of national
security
to the president of the united states if
you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video